Hello.
Yeah, I've got my crowbar.
It's so funny.
Actually, I googled... I googled... Oh my gosh.
Brian, thank you.
I don't know if I'm going to go yet or not.
I did see Stephanie being there at the Metal Gear concert in London is very tempting.
I'm not going to lie.
Since last time I went to the Metal Gear concert, it was Donna Burke and Cynthia Carell.
But if I could see Stephanie too.
Joostin.
Is that how you say it?
Joostin?
Like juicin?
Anyway, what was I saying?
Oh my gosh.
I got distracted because of Metal Gear.
Of course I did.
Oh, I googled... I googled crowbar PNG earlier.
And this came up and it was just like, this is the crowbar from Half-Life 2.
I was like, what?
Oh my gosh.
Joostin?
More like Joostin.
Oh, okay.
I thought so.
I was like, I don't think it's Joostin.
But it makes me want some juice.
It's a popular crowbar.
It must be.
My crowbar from the future.
Whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on.
I'm going to actually rearrange.
There we go.
That should be better.
That should be good.
Surface tension is my favorite part of the game.
If that is a reference, I don't get it.
Time paradox.
Anyway, welcome back to Half-Life.
Last time we were about to go into...
Another part of the map.
It's a chapter.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we were just about to start another chapter.
My ass is heavy.
Is that another reference?
Why are you guys sending me references that I don't understand?
Why would you... I don't... I don't get it.
I don't get it.
Are these references?
I'm guessing.
I... I... I... I don't... I don't know.
I... I'm... I'm assuming because I don't understand the context otherwise.
Happy Koharu Day.
Um...
I always treat Koharu very well.
Thank you.
You should watch videos with Half-Life sound effects dubbing memes.
Let me play the games first.
Let's... let me... let me get through the...
Oh, gosh.
Was this a mistake?
Everybody's now just saying memes and I don't get them.
And...
Why... why wasn't it... why was it normal before?
And now it's... now... now everybody's insufferable.
What's happening?
I feel like the first time I played it was fine.
Yeah, Half-Life Full-Life Consequences.
That's the only thing I understand.
Because that's the only video I've ever seen.
More like spend half of my life for the next day's combat.
Soon you will be part of the meme culture.
I feel like though, it's not...
Is it... isn't it most of Half-Life memes from like...
The... the videos people make?
Or am I... remembering that wrong?
Hmm...
Most... yeah, mostly.
So...
Yeah, I guess...
Well, I have to play the games first anyway.
I have to play the games first anyway.
So...
Wait, you are playing Half-Life for the first time?
Yes.
Yeah, I've never played it before.
99% of Half-Life memes are skippity-toilet.
We don't... we don't talk about those ones.
Actually, has...
I'm so curious though.
Has skippity-toilet been accepted by like the...
Half-Life...
Grandpas and Grandmas of the world.
Do they all say like...
You know what?
At least the kids are getting into the...
Getting into it.
No!
Also, Gumpul, happy birthday!
Can I ask for a...
What's a special birthday song?
What's a special one?
Hmm...
Um...
I could do in like Simlish.
Gapul-ibu...
Deed-o...
Gapul...
Gapul-ibu...
Deed-o...
Woooo....
There you go.
Let's see.
All right.
Wait.
Where?
This must be it.
Wait.
Yeah.
I realized I ended the stream and then I like walked away from my computer and I came back and I never closed out of the game.
So grandpa is here for the... Yeah.
Yeah.
So.
Okay.
Load.
I think it was F6 for quicksave.
No?
All right.
Let's get back into it.
Let's get back into... Okay.
Hold on.
Hold on, sir.
I'm remembering how to use the controls.
Okay.
And then I select.
Double crowbar.
Do I just pick up things automatically?
Uh... Oh.
Oh!
Wait!
Redo!
Undo!
Wait!
Hold on.
I just messed up.
We need to go that way, grandpa.
And then this is to heal my suit and this is to heal my... Wait.
This... Oh.
That's unfortunate.
That's unfortunate as well.
You ready, grandpa?
Let's get my guns out.
Get your guns out.
Wait.
How do I... Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Grandpa?
You ready?
What was that?
Oh.
I'm gonna keep you safe, grandpa.
Oh, gosh.
Uh... I don't know what the blast pit is, but it sounds dangerous.
Oh.
I think I need to blast this.
That doesn't sound good.
Grandpa?
Watch out.
Uh...
This
is as far as I go.
Uh... I think you're gonna die in there.
I'm
gonna...
I'm gonna blast it.
Uh-oh.
Grandpa!
I think I need to reload.
Oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh...
Oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on, mister.
Let's go.
Yep.
Yeah.
Oh, wrong way.
This way.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Oh, that's my flashlight.
Oh, my God.
It scared me for a second.
Oh.
Uh...
This way.
Okay.
What is that sound?
I'm scared.
What is that?
Oh, the crowbar instead?
So true.
Something... Oh, something's totally in there, destroying everything.
Nah, yeah, don't worry about it.
I wonder if I can get him from here.
Okay, all right.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna... I'm gonna... Wait.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, I hear him.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Where'd he go?
Wait.
I don't remember what gun is good.
You're safe!
He's really appreciative.
What's... What was spitting?
Oh.
Whatever that is.
I think I got it.
Oh, ouchy, ouch!
You son of a gun.
I got it.
Whatever it was.
Don't worry about it.
First try.
So true.
Ah!
First try.
So true.
Let's just... This is the shoddy, right?
I'm going to stay here and wait for my colleagues.
I hear another one.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Oh, golly!
I hear something else though.
No?
Danger.
Very cool.
Is that another crowbar?
In case you lose your old crowbar?
If you find Dr. Kummer, tell him I said, hello, Gordon.
I hear it.
Oh, wait.
I hear it though.
Fascinating.
I never suspected such things could be.
Alright.
Let's go press the button, I suppose.
Pull the lever.
Do you what?
Do you...
Wait.
Do not do...
Do a wheel?
It won't let me.
I don't think so.
Sorry, I can't speak sometimes.
Let's ignore that for now.
And press this.
Oh, just kidding.
Let's go downstairs.
Oh, wait.
I did the thing.
It did work.
Oh, golly.
What's coming up?
Um...
Wouldn't you like to get one of these blood samples under a microscope?
Shut up, doctor.
We have important things.
Oh!
Ouch.
Is there anything else in here?
I guess not.
Okay.
Metal Gear has trained me for elevators.
I need to switch my gun.
To this one instead.
Oh, the recoil.
Oh, I'd...
Die.
Yeah.
Where'd the other one go?
Oh, look.
A tram.
Yeah.
Oh.
Wonder what that could be for.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, there's two of them.
Three of them!
Four of them!
Wait!
No!
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
There he is.
Come on, please.
Oh, my...
My ammo.
They're kind of cute.
They are pretty cute.
I'm not going to lie.
I don't want to take the tram.
Okay.
You know what?
Let's just take the tram.
Let's give my little leggies a rest.
Wee!
Oh!
Okay.
Full steam ahead!
Can I run into this thing?
Oh, God.
Oops.
Um...
Not anymore!
Oh!
Something's going off.
Oh, gosh!
We're...
Oh.
Look at this guy.
He's like, If you don't see me...
Dang it.
Hold on.
Let's just use my pistol.
What is this?
Stop.
Shut up.
Why are we saying rip?
Is the...
Headcrab more important to you?
Than my life?
He was a chill guy.
He was pretty chill.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay.
I'm trying to jump up here.
All right.
Oh.
Okay.
What's that look...
Oh.
Oh, my God!
Where did you come from?
I think I got him.
Go back on the train and forward.
Wait, what do you mean?
Really?
I think it's broken.
I don't think it's working anymore.
It's broke, broke.
And we gotta go this way.
Okay.
We're fine.
It's just radioactivity.
Nothing to be afraid of, probably.
Just Geiger sounds.
Totally normal.
Why are things down here, anyway?
Why are things in here?
Okay.
We're going in the pipes.
Where?
Where did you come from?
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
Where did you come from?
Ah!
You son-of-a-gun.
Is black-haired minto called licorice?
No, I'm calling minto.
Wait, there's probably some stuff on here too, no?
Where are you?
Where'd he go?
Maybe he fell into the goop.
Is there anything over there, you think?
Nah, right?
Maybe?
But then why would there be boxes for me to, you know, jump on top of?
Oh, this is, this is pretty spooky.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't think I like this.
Handy-dandy pistol.
I don't like these ones the most.
Maybe these guys suck.
Ow!
Oops.
Got his ass.
Didn't get his ass.
Oh, didn't get his ass.
Reloading.
Killed him.
If I...
Oh, god.
I'm trapped in the pipe!
Wait, how do I actually get out?
How do I get out of the pipe?
Oh.
Just like that.
Someone suggested a grenade.
And you know what?
I think that's a grand idea.
Alley-oop!
Nice!
Do you think the bull squids are bad here?
Try the HD fan remake Black Mesa.
They're a nightmare.
Oh, yeah.
That's the thing that people were like, Why don't you play Black Mesa instead?
And I said, I don't know.
I want to play the original.
Actually, though, this has been really tickling like that.
Oh, no!
Oh.
I'm okay.
I'm fine.
But this has been scratching that, uh...
Not the radioactive itch, But the, um...
Like the doom itch that I've kind of been having lately.
So...
I'm kind of happy about that.
Just, like, wanting to play like a...
Old...
FPS.
Kind of dealio.
High radiation area.
You don't say!
30% What's...
Power cold?
Yeah, like a boomer shooter.
Oh!
Oops!
My bad.
Sorry.
I accidentally right clicked.
You nasty creature, you.
Oh my gosh!
Let's see.
Where do we go from here?
What's in that?
What's that?
How about Quake?
Oh, yeah!
I do want to play Quake sometime.
Can I push this?
Look, there's something...
There's stuff over there.
How do I get to it?
Hmm, curious.
Black Mesa is for two kinds of people.
People without the patience for old games.
And people who played the old games wanting a new take on them.
That makes sense.
Oh gosh.
What was that?
Ow!
Ouch!
You...
Bitch!
Oh.
Uh.
It's fine.
He's stuck.
Dog's stuck.
Dog's stuck!
Um.
I'll kill him eventually, right?
There we go.
Yeah.
Whew!
What about the stuff over there, though?
I kind of want to grab that.
Hmm.
Jump?
Jump where?
You can try.
Save?
Oh, so true.
Yeah, let's save and then...
Hold on.
How can I...
I couldn't get around the barrel, though.
Maybe if I...
Okay.
Let me...
Wait.
Let me go back.
Can I even make this?
I don't think I can.
Oh.
I touched the...
I touched the green.
Oh.
Um.
I don't know if I can make it.
I think I messed up.
Get on the slanted portion.
Of what?
This?
Oh.
Oops.
Uh.
Ignore the Geiger sounds?
What's this, anyway?
Okay, anyway.
Um.
Uh.
Yeah.
Anyway.
What a thrill.
Darkness and silence through the night.
You think grandpa's okay?
Bad
dog.
Bad, bad dog.
Oh, grandpa.
I guess I could have blown him up with that.
Oopsie.
Wait.
Is that a green?
Ouch!
Oh my god, the dogs.
Non-stop dogs.
Wait, there's a green dog.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe if I pistol this part?
Oh, how do I... Oh, no.
Wait a second.
Will this happen too?
Oh, that's not good.
I think.
Ah!
Hmm.
That one exploded way more than this one did.
Uh, let's do our best.
If not, I'll just reload.
Easy.
I can make this.
Wait, this guy's trying to explode at me.
Nasty.
Sucker over there.
Dead.
Oh, and there's like two head crabs.
Yeah, cool.
The head crabs are on the other side waving.
They're like, Hey, me too!
Just jump!
Like so.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Access.
I'm afraid to save though.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
Oh, I'm making this ruckus.
What the hell?
Oh, shut up.
Is that me?
For real?
Oh, I-I don't think that's...
Shit, doesn't know.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm scared!
Wait.
Do you think I can- Do you think I can quick save?
Or am I gonna be, uh...
Am I-Will I be, um...
Soft locked.
Manual save?
Let's try that, yeah.
New save.
Save.
There's cows in here!
Oh, you're alive!
Wait.
That's a- Rocket engine.
Destroy the damned thing before it grows any larger.
Stop!
Oh!
Okay.
Oh.
Shit.
I'm scared of going in there!
Oh no!
I don't think I could have done anything.
I just feel like, there was nothing that could be done.
Oh, what's this thing?
So if I test fire... Oops, it didn't hear that right?
Oh, it didn't hear that right?
Wait, oh!
Oh, it doesn't see me.
Okay, good.
Woah!
Look at the terminal.
So what, I need the power and the oxygen and the fuel?
Try shooting.
Wait, what's going on there?
What is happening?
Wait, what is happening here?
Can I shoot this thing?
They're green people!
Oh.
Sorry.
Sorry!
He left them alone, at least.
I'm gonna...
I mean, I kind of want to see what's going on.
Oh!
They stop as soon as I come in.
Alright.
I've never noticed that before.
Now there's all these interesting sounds and everything.
I probably can go up this without getting caught, right?
Die!
Oh!
It's dead.
Oh my god!
Oh god!
Barney, you scared the crap out of me!
Oh.
Okay, be quiet.
Roger that.
Let's run like hell.
No!
Be quiet!
Barney!
You're just so... No!
Crouch!
Don't run!
Oh!
That's the room.
Okay, Barney, you stay here.
I'll stay here and guard this area.
Yeah, yeah.
Pretty much.
Let's run like hell.
No, you don't do that.
Wait, so... I'm gonna...
I'm gonna save again.
Sorry.
Which... Which was me?
I don't know.
You know what?
It's fine.
Here we go.
Oh gosh, how do I go down the stairs?
Uh, ladder.
Oh!
Um...
I think I'm in trouble.
Oopsie!
Okay.
Oh, we're so fine.
See?
Okay, I'm gonna get my crowbar out.
Even though...
Well, that didn't really make a difference, I think.
But it's fine.
Okay.
Alright, very carefully.
Oh, he's so cool though.
I feel like I hear some other stuff around.
No?
Oh no.
How am I supposed to move those boxes?
This doesn't seem good.
Um...
Just grenade them?
Really?
Will it work?
Beep.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Let's see if I distract them over...
That!
Oh.
Whoops.
My bad.
I didn't realize I had it selected.
Over!
That way!
I'm scared.
As soon as I start beating this...
As soon as I start beating this up, they're gonna get all...
Use grenades to break the boxes.
I mean...
But then they'll be all...
Clanky on this part, no?
This part used to scare me as a kid, I believe it.
Oh.
Okay, hold on.
One more.
Yes!
Okay.
Now...
Um...
Okay, now...
Uh!
Yeah, ignore...
Ignore this...
Ignore the ladder.
There you go.
Anything...
Oh my god, they're so noisy, though.
Shut up!
God, all the noise is coming from you!
Bozos.
I don't think they appreciated that.
Is there anything in there?
Hey!
Where am I supposed to go?
Hold on, I'm trying to check the...
Bottom area.
Oh, maybe down there?
Okay, what I'm gonna do is...
We're gonna...
Wait, do I have enough grenades?
Five hole grenades!
Okay, I'm gonna blow up these two doors, okay?
Easy does it, Gordon.
Yes!
Oh my god!
Goal!
Did you see that?
That was crazy!
Wow!
That was so good!
Maybe I should've done the lower one...
After...
You know what, it's fine.
Okay.
Oops.
And...
Uh-oh, I have three left.
There's...
Through!
Yes!
Sorry.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
No load.
Save.
No save.
Okay.
What do I hear?
I just hear something squelching around a bit.
I don't...
I can't tell if it's this guy or not.
He'll get tired...
Oh my god!
You know...
Stupid...
Blind...
Okay.
Now...
We go back to Shoddy.
Oh wait...
Was it this...
Level or...
The one underneath?
Underneath.
Where was that guy?
Hmm.
Back to shiny.
Ah, we're on this side.
Oh my God.
What?
You expect me... What do I... What is this?
Ah!
Me too.
Yes.
That's me.
Yeah.
Okay.
Everything's fine, guys.
Ignore.
Nobody does it quite like you.
I think actually many people probably have done that before.
Raise your hand if you've fallen off these pipes.
Everybody's gonna raise their hands.
Sorry, I'm not using the quicksave right now because I am scared about that area.
I don't know if I've accidentally softlocked myself or not.
So that's why I haven't been using the... But I am very well aware of it.
I am very well aware of quicksave.
I just don't know if I've accidentally softlocked.
You haven't?
Don't worry.
Really?
How can you be so short?
What are you, a genius?
What?
Have you played this game before or something?
What am I... What am I hearing?
Oh.
This guy.
Oh, there's another one?
Somewhere?
Maybe?
Joke's on you.
I've never played Half-Life 1.
Oh.
There's definitely another guy somewhere around here.
What?
What is the purpose of this area anyway?
See?
Ah!
Wait, I need a grandpa!
Oh, shoot.
Wait, maybe there's a grandpa down here.
Oh, there he is.
I see him.
You nasty.
Auto-activate.
Open.
Open, Sesame.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, I'm gonna trust...
I'm gonna quicksave...
Anyone with an elderly parrot that they don't need?
Let's go down.
Why am I in the sewers?
Is this radioactive?
I guess not.
Ew!
Oh.
Nasty man.
There we go.
Okay.
He won't bother us anymore.
No Geiger clickers.
Yes, no Geiger clickers.
We'll just...
We'll just stick with the shotgun for now.
Uh...
This way?
Nope.
Oh, I'm smelly.
I'm so stinky nasty.
Ooh.
I'm in the gross water.
I'm sure...
Hope no one...
Is he in the water?
No way.
No stinking way.
Okay.
I'm gonna have to...
Woo!
That works.
Oh, there.
Oh.
Wait.
I'm like so close.
Come on.
Gordon, just use your arms.
Oof, ammo.
You're so right.
Actually, oof, ammo on all fronts.
Um...
Where he might be in trouble.
Jump and crouch.
Okay.
Wait.
Uh.
That didn't...
That doesn't work.
Uh.
Yeah.
That doesn't work.
Oh, man.
I'm gonna have to balance the whole way?
That sucks.
Is there anything up here that I can...
Immediately shoot?
No?
Okay.
He's a physicist, not an athlete.
I know.
I just thought, you know...
He might...
Have a little muscle on him.
He's got string bean arms.
It's not his fault.
Wait.
Do I actually have to go through this entire thing?
How do I...
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He's such a...
He's so sen...
Like, the controls here.
The controls are so...
Sensitive.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Holy.
Okay.
I'm losing my balance.
Woo-woo-woo-woo-woo-woo-woo.
Yeah!
Okay, I'm fine.
Ugh.
Oops.
Oh.
More grenades.
Thank you.
What do I hear?
Wait.
Shift is walk, by the way.
Oh, thank you.
You know what?
I think I do remember that.
Nice.
I guess I could've.
Ready for some CQC.
I hope you're enjoying the gaming, though.
I love the series as much as you love MGS.
Thank you, Felix.
Yeah, I'm having so much fun.
Stop.
You're making the door open and close.
I can't get rid of him.
Oh, he's like doing that typical horror movie trope.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Why does it look like red eyes looking at me?
Oh, it's the legs.
Thank you.
What?
Why does it do that?
Why is it so aggressive?
Wait, Gordon Freeman.
Gordon Freeman, please.
Oh, gosh.
Excuse me.
Close quarters, crowbar.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
This is... OSHA would like to have a word.
Quick save here.
I'm saved.
Is it gonna break the things at the top?
Wait, what do you mean too late?
What do you mean?
Huh?
Do I go down?
I can turn it off.
Oh, do I need to bomb it?
Do I need to...
Oh, oh.
That was close.
Do I need to, uh...
Grenade?
Grenade it.
You need to get up quickly.
Go up as soon as you turn it on.
Okay.
Go up as soon as...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
OSHA would come in and shoot everybody.
Why is the ladder like...
All right.
Okay, I'm gonna be...
Well, I just saved.
It's fine.
Run!
Oh.
Oh, I did it.
Easy peasy.
All right.
Very nice.
So that's one thing, no?
I guess.
Now jump?
Oh!
Ah!
I got it.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Are those lasers or...
Is this just...
Red room is scary.
Don't...
What did I...
Oh, I got hurt.
Don't mess with me, little headcrab.
Oh, I hear something.
Oh.
Just some...
Just some regular...
Regular roaches.
Have you tried swinging a crowbar twice a second IRL?
You need mad grip strength.
I believe that.
Oh, is that something like...
There's...
Oh.
He's like...
Oh my god.
He's like waiting for me right there.
He's gonna...
He's gonna jump at me as soon as I break this!
Spawn camping.
Real.
There's nothing else in here?
I guess we're just in a vent, so...
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
I assume I'm going the correct way.
Alright.
Hold on.
Nothing over here?
Nothing?
Okay.
What am I hearing?
What is that?
Okay.
Oh, you.
Where did he go?
The other guy.
Okay.
Alright.
Bro went away.
He's like, I'm not...
I don't have time to deal with this.
I just don't have...
I just don't have the time.
Alright, anything else in here?
We got some tubes.
Man, watching...
This really makes me think about how much better ladders have become in games.
I know!
It really makes you appreciate it, huh?
Oxygen!
Fuel on!
Okay.
Powering on the stuff.
Very nice.
Nice.
Oh.
My bad.
And here we are on the other side.
Very cool.
Okay.
What's all...
The sound now.
You think Barney's okay?
Whoa!
Neat.
Okay.
Um...
Let's heal.
And let's save.
And let's do our...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna walk.
I'm gonna walk across.
And now...
Presenting...
Mint Phantom.
Doing...
The High Rope...
Walkway.
Oh.
Okay.
It was very unimpressive.
Nevermind.
Nobody...
Nobody cared.
Wait, so now...
Was...
It was...
Wait, now I have to go...
Probably to the bottom to get the power, right?
Because there was three things needed?
I cared.
Wait, why did I...
Why did my health go down?
Oh...
So rude.
Stinking guys.
I didn't even fall!
Oh, they're like kinda camping like...
That ladder.
That's why I think.
Let's see.
Oh!
He just...
He treated me like a damn bird.
He was like...
Beep beep!
What the hell was that?
Alright.
Turn all your efforts to the other side.
Thank you.
Yes, yes.
Little boop boop.
Wait, oh, this is the door.
I was like...
What door did I break down?
Did you actually save that, Barney?
Normally, he runs at the tentacles and gets smashed.
Talking to him must have stopped that.
Really?
I am a savior!
A friend to Barney.
Alright, we got this.
Whoop!
Wanna see something cool?
Press a wall and press T?
Hi graffiti!
What?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, can I make this?
Uh oh.
T.
Oh, I can't do it again.
Uh...
I think so.
Crouch jump.
Don't forget the crouch jump.
But I gotta get a running start, no?
Hold on.
Once again.
Okay, here we go.
Whoop!
Oh, sorry.
Uh...
Okay, hold on.
Oh, I don't need to crouch jump.
Three little guys in a row.
I think you can customize the spray.
Oh, neat.
Oh, you can.
Okay.
Once again.
I am saving.
That's the one that I broke big time, I think.
And I killed this guy.
Ugh.
Dogs.
Okay, come here, dog.
Yep, come here, dog.
Okay.
It's like...
It feel...
It reminds me of like, uh...
The...
Dogs in like...
Silent Hill.
Okay.
I imagine...
This is gonna be like, electrified.
Once we turn on the power, huh?
Is this gonna be like...
Okay, let's test our...
Oh, we're so dead.
But chirpier.
Hmm.
He's just feasting away.
Good observation.
Good to know that...
I might be right.
And...
Oh.
That's...
That kinda sucks.
Um...
He's like, what the hell was that?
He's joking.
He doesn't know at all what hit him.
Uh...
Excuse me!
Oh my gosh, I thought that was a rope.
Oh!
That scared...
Wait, there's multiple of them!
I thought they were ropes for...
Because there's these ropes!
Wait, there's so many of them!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
What?
Oh wait.
No, please.
Please don't do this to me.
What's that?
Come on.
There we go.
Nice, nice.
Ah, yeah!
Okay.
I wish I could get stuff for my...
For my armor, but for now we just...
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna forget these guys are here for real.
We'll be fine though.
Probably.
Oh!
Whoa!
This game is so atmospheric.
It's awesome.
Uh-oh.
Who is...
Who is here?
It's so science.
You're right, madam.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh, boy.
What do you mean by that?
What's happening?
There's...
There's four guys on that elevator!
Oh!
Wait, do I need to jump?
Oh.
Uh...
Jump to the ladder.
Let's see it.
Ah!
What a thrill.
With darkness.
Wait, I was going down, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Silence through the night.
What a thrill.
Um...
Stuck?
A ladder.
Okay.
Mr. Scientist!
Get behind me, scientist.
What's here?
I hope no one needs to start up the generator.
Smithers went down there and never came back.
Okay.
Good to know.
Smithers.
That guy is probably now...
Oh.
Sorry.
He's still talking.
I was gonna say he's now smithereens.
Oh.
You do?
What?
Was that a sneeze?
Okay.
I'll protect him.
I'll protect you.
Einstein.
Oh.
What the hell was...
Oh, was that?
I was like, what is that running around up there?
What is this?
Oh.
Hate that.
Let's just chill it in the...
Wait, am I...
Did I hit him or no?
I think from here.
Good.
Your aim sucks.
Little dog.
Ahem.
Oh.
I'm depending...
I need more ammo.
Game, please.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh God.
Okay.
Oh.
So then I...
Climb.
Okay.
It's a little puzzle, huh?
I think...
Oh gosh.
But this thing will kill me.
No?
Oh.
Yeah.
I have to be so fast.
Oh my God.
This part makes no sense.
What?
Shotty sniping.
I know.
Oh.
Ah.
I guess I can go to either one.
Okay.
Cool.
We're going to this one.
Okay.
Oh no.
Smithers.
That has to be him, right?
Oh.
That's you, right?
Smithers.
But...
This is my hiding spot.
So I'm not moving until the situation is drastically improved.
Now go away.
And don't tell anyone I'm here.
He's not old Smithereens.
I think he's about to be though.
Once I turn this on, no?
Okay.
Good luck, old man.
Wait.
Do I have to do each side?
Don't tell me.
Wait.
Uh oh.
I just activated something else.
Hey boo.
Okay.
They're both sides.
Um.
Uh okay.
Oh.
What is this?
Ah.
Oh dear.
What's happening?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Uh.
Ah.
Oh dear.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Run where are you guys?
I think we're about to be exploded.
Oh dear.
Maybe onto this tightrope.
Oh.
I go in here?
Whoa.
Dang Gordon.
Into the light.
Go into the light.
Wait.
How do I get down from here?
I think I'm...
I think I'm dead for real.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I can't jump from here.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Like a moth to a flame.
Go in?
Really?
Touch it?
Okay...
Yeah... Tastes like blue raspberry.
Thank you for the... Oh no!
Okay, we're fine.
Thank you for the rain!
I'm
a little trapped right now.
I'm a little...
I'm a bit in a predicament.
I think I just need to fall.
Wait, can I climb down this?
Oh...
Holy...
I'm alive!
Wait...
Oh yeah, I just pressed this button.
Okay, we get back.
Yippee!
I think we made it.
Thank you guys for the gift and thank you!
Was that a high-pitched, goofy laugh?
No?
I saw...
Someone has restored all power.
We'll have the engine up again in no time.
That's me!
Give me credit.
Credit where credit is due.
Ask the doctor to heal you?
Oh, shoot.
With my brains and I'm slowing you down.
Nevermind.
Sorry.
We're not gonna come back here anyway.
I guess it's fine.
Oh, um...
Oh.
Doctor.
It's so dark.
Lurker, thank you so much!
Oh, how do I...
Thank you for the...
Do I...
Do I jump?
No way.
Fall with style.
Oof!
Major fracture detected.
Oh!
Oh, ouch.
Oh, man.
I fell with style and with grace.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, I knew this was coming.
Okay.
Ah.
Alright.
Hmm.
The boxes.
Yes.
That's what I was thinking.
Can I...
Yeah.
Like so.
Come here.
Oh, my gosh.
Watch out.
I wish I wasn't so bad at grabbing these.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Dang it.
Why is this so difficult?
Ugh.
Wait.
Okay.
There we go.
Old game.
Yeah.
That's okay.
We got this.
Okay.
Nice.
There's one.
Grab.
Okay.
That was actually pretty good.
Nice.
Okay.
And then...
A little bit more.
We make a little bridge.
I probably only need like...
A little bit.
I think...
I only need a few and then I can just jump across the rest.
We're doing sides.
Yes.
She's cooking, your honor.
She doesn't know.
I don't know.
What are you talking about?
Of course I don't know.
I've never played this game before.
Oh.
Okay.
I think we'll make it.
Ignore what the lady says.
You technically made it.
Dang it.
I thought we would have more.
I thought we would have had more of a...
You know.
Oh my god.
Now we have to go...
All the way back up.
Thank you for the soup.
Uh...
You're welcome.
How many grenades do we have anyway?
Eight.
Turning it down.
The clanging is too much.
I'm manually saving.
Why are they green?
Cause they're really special.
It's their favorite color.
Okay.
Nice.
It's my favorite color too.
Oh my gosh.
Is that why your name is...
Vert?
Ver?
However you pronounce...
Oops.
Uh...
That was a failure.
Wait a minute.
Maybe it wasn't a failure.
Oh.
Actually...
That worked.
Today is the...
My birthday!
Skeleton soup!
Happy birthday!
Give me a second.
I'll sing...
Happy birthday.
Oh god.
No!
No please!
I will die!
That's not exactly where I needed you to focus on.
But what we will do...
Maybe it's okay actually.
That guy's like just poking right next to it.
Never mind.
He's poking it.
Okay.
Hold on.
Over...
There!
And I thought he was gonna go after me!
Skeleton soup!
Happy birthday to...
You...
Happy...
Birthday...
To...
You...
Happy birthday...
Dear...
Skeleton soup...
Happy birthday... to you...
Happy birthday!
Let's get some more grenades.
I wish... I wish this was ammo...
that I could take.
Hey there, Barney.
Excuse me.
Please move.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, save.
Oh, it's Barney.
Sorry, I said Bernie.
Test fire!
I'm on fire?
Wait, I'm on fire, I think.
Am I gonna die?
Wait, is Barney okay?
He's probably fine.
Oh.
Thank you for your sacrifice.
Now what?
Do I go all the way down there?
In the hole.
I think he's okay.
He probably got out just in time.
And like, just left a little bit of a...
You know.
He accidentally dropped some...
STUFF!
Hehehe...
Ah, m...
Shucks.
Hehehehehe...
Death by...
Weak knees...
Hehehehehe...
I was too silly...
Okay.
Alright.
We'll get it this time.
Gamers!
Alright, gamers!
I
have weakness!
Gees!
Liger counter.
New gun!
Oh gosh, why is it so spooky down here for real?
Oh!
Doctor!
Are you okay?
Oh!
What the hell is that?
Okay.
Is that the rest of the guy?
Six shots.
It's the root.
Okay, that didn't quite do what I thought it would do.
We still have slot four open.
I wonder what that will be.
Alright.
Don't worry, he's dead.
Okay, okay.
Let's try our new gun.
Wow!
Oh gosh.
Oh, okay.
Oh god.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
No way!
Oh, this is down.
Okay.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
New gun!
Don't touch the...
Don't touch that.
Is there... Is there like a door or something that I missed?
Wait...
Wait!
I'm gonna die!
User death imminent.
Can I get a hint here?
What do I...
Where do I go?
I can't tell at all.
Can I get a hint?
I'm stuck.
Just...
You go through the water just the other way.
Down, side, up.
I have to swim up one of the sides.
Do I have enough HP?
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I almost didn't make it.
That was close.
That was a close...
What was that?
That was a close one.
Oh!
Oh, there they are.
They're just floating in circles.
Health!
Please!
Wait, I'm gonna save here.
There we go.
Watch as I drop to my death.
Oh my gosh!
And the armor!
This is big!
We're doing it!
Yeah!
Alright, alright, alright.
Now let's go back up.
Very good.
And save again.
He's admiring the revolver!
Wait!
Does he do that for all the guns?
Let's try the pistol.
Do you like the pistol too?
He's kinda playing with it, but the revolver, he felt things.
I could tell.
I could tell!
Just an orange box!
Alright.
Let's go.
Onward!
I think this is...
The way I'm supposed to go.
Or...
Not.
Oh wait, yes maybe.
Yes.
They're so cute!
They're like little...
School children.
Little ducks.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Oh...
I was gonna say, this is...
This is kinda mean.
Yeah.
Wait.
Yep.
Okay.
Easy.
Easy!
What's in here?
Oh, did I just get hurt from that?
Hell no.
Oh.
Dang it.
Hold on.
I'm not...
Save scumming or anything.
I'm...
You know.
Gord.
Gordy.
Gordo!
Oh.
Say we're fine.
4 HP...
I...
I'm...
I'm at half life.
Actually, maybe I'm playing the game correctly.
What are you...
To send a real one.
I hope you're having fun touring the Gatorade factory.
I don't...
This is my least favorite Gatorade flavor.
I'd say.
Okay.
Oi!
Alright.
You can jump from above?
Oh.
You can?
But I gotta make it into the hole.
I'm not good at getting off the ladders once I'm on.
Okay.
Let's try this.
A wheel?
Oh!
This!
I did miss that.
Thank you.
Oh.
Uh.
Oh!
Yippee!
Alright.
Okay.
Where...
Where does he even think he's going?
Happy New Year!
Membo!
Thank you!
Toxic waste is your least favorite Gatorade flavor?
Yeah.
I can't say he's my favorite.
I pre...
I much prefer...
Rat poison.
I saw that little guy under the table too.
That guy's waiting to ambush me also.
This place is so...
Not great...
At keeping up...
With...
Their...
Um, you know...
Everything.
Wait...
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh!
Alright, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
So...
How do I do this?
Do I...
Go down?
Yeah, but...
What the?!
Aim for the table.
Okay.
Oh!
We got that guy.
Good!
That was so nice!
What is this?
Wait, what is this?
What did I grab?
What is this?
A projector.
Okay.
There's little booties and stuff in here.
Oh, wait.
These are the ones that I push.
Move, please.
It's a camera.
What else did I just grab?
How do I use it?
It looks like...
It doesn't look like a camera at all.
It looks like a projector, you guys.
It even is projecting in the photo.
Like in its little...
Oh, it's a mine!
Oh!
Wait, let's try it.
Power up.
Oh!
What's going on there?
He's got by donning him.
I see.
Wait a second.
I understand how it works now.
Did I get everything in here?
What is...
What's with these though?
Maybe if I wanted to get back up?
Okay, anyway.
Um...
Do I have...
Not a lot of ammo.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm also going for it!
Wait, um...
Maybe I should run.
These guys seem kind of dumb.
Oh.
Ah!
I
think he got me in one shot.
Ew!
Gee, man.
Holy cow.
What am I hearing?
I don't...
Oh my gosh.
Of course.
Where are they?
Oh, here you are.
Hey!
Stupid.
Oh, there's like so...
Oh!
Wow!
There goes all my ammo.
Um...
Dammit!
Oh!
I think I got...
Dang it!
Okay.
Um...
Where...
Ah...
I'm...
I'm doing my best!
Gosh!
I'm doing my best here!
Okay.
All right.
Oh, the revolver!
That's right!
Forgot I got it.
He's gone.
Where did he go?
Ah!
No, booby!
Oh, booby!
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh my gosh.
Don't see me.
Um...
Track power is now...
Oh!
All the way from here!
Okay, uh...
Um...
Revolver!
Now you know why they call me revolver!
Uh...
All right.
Oh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Dang, it's so powerful!
And then...
Um...
I'll just keep using it.
There it is.
Oh.
Stop admiring the gun and shoot it!
I'm Ocelot real!
Wooo!
Hahaha!
Sick shots!
Oh!
Ouch!
Um...
I'm gonna die!
Oh!
This is suffering!
I have, like, no health at all!
Hahaha!
This...
Oh, wait.
That's the...
There's that other guy coming through, huh?
Wait, where is he?
Pro tip.
I think I just took more damage.
Oh my god.
That could've gotten me.
But I think I just activated a...
Uh-oh.
Uh...
He sounds like he's walking around.
Yeah!
What else do I hear clicking?
Okay.
I don't know.
Mister, you can get the power on.
That train will take us straight to the surface.
Ah...
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
What did you say?
Hey!
Things in the way.
Hold on.
I didn't see your super chat.
I'm sorry.
What did you say?
Oh, the black hair with the twin tails is really cute.
I'm glad you like it!
Thank you!
Okay.
I feel like I'm stupid for saving here, but I will.
Can I get him?
Without him noticing me?
He's spawn camping?
Oh my god!
I'll do my best for you, Barney!
I'll do my best!
That's not power?
What do you mean that- Oh, it still says off.
Wait, where's the power?
What was that?
If that's not the power?
Oh, it's downstairs.
Oh!
Wait, what is this then?
Oh,
it's the track alignment.
Oh.
You're...
Well, I still have to do this...
Anyway, right?
Probably?
Right!
Oh, you don't have to do it now.
Oh, actually, I just noticed.
Yeah, because we need to get the thing.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is gonna be hellish, no?
This is...
This is gonna be so hellish!
Oh my god.
I hate everything.
You got this, Gammer.
Where?
Oh, ew.
Uh-oh.
I'm reloading.
Please.
Sir, understand.
There we go.
Okay.
There's health here.
The thrill of reloading in battle!
Power generator track control.
15 HP.
More than enough to kill it.
Oh.
Yay!
What's this do?
Oh.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to open the door.
There we go.
Alright.
Ooh.
Warning.
Hazard this waste.
Oh, okay.
That...
Opens and closes it.
Wow.
It's so pretty.
You would not believe your eyes.
10 million fireflies.
Ah!
No.
Let's go!
Well, whatever was up there is...
Dead now?
Let's go!
Yeah, move in!
Move in!
Let's go!
Oh.
Move in!
Why did he explode?
Okay.
Alright.
I just gotta...
I just gotta go for it.
I
just gotta go for it.
Let's go!
Okay.
Alright.
Uh...
Shoddy, baby.
Yeah, that never happened.
Never happened.
There we go!
Wait, there's a second one.
Oh no, that's a radio.
Ah!
No!
You bastard!
Anyway.
Back to me trying to heal.
Okay.
Oof.
I've got a crowbar.
I'm really not afraid to use it.
In fact, I would be happy to do so.
What is this though?
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to destroy these first.
What are you?
Shut up!
You're annoying.
Um...
I hope I didn't need whatever that was.
As I think about it.
Whatever the maintenance...
Things were.
It's...
Fine.
Okay.
Alright.
I've collected everything.
Collected everything.
We can...
Now...
I've saved.
We can go.
Doesn't save.
Thank you!
You ready to kick some soldier ass?
Where are they?
Squad!
Good job clearing blast pit, by the way.
That area is super tricky.
Oh, thank you!
Where are they?
Ouch!
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie!
Wait, where'd you come from?
Where did you come from, for real?
You...
Son of a gun.
Oh, wait.
I'm back where I came from.
Um...
Dang it.
That guy got me.
That guy got me good.
I'm dead.
Okay, I'm going up.
Ugh.
I'm so dead.
Reload.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yes.
This...
This is where I reloaded.
Okay.
I'm...
I'm okay.
This is fine.
You could use the laser mines here.
Okay.
Save.
The thrill of reloading in battle.
I don't think I get it.
I get it.
Hossalaad, I don't...
I don't understand you.
Hossalaad, I don't think I get it.
I don't think I understand.
I don't think I understand it.
Okay.
What was that?
Save.
All right.
And...
Reload.
Yes, thank you.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch.
Leave me alone.
Where'd you go?
Oh.
Oh wait, I don't... Maybe I'll switch to this instead.
Oh my god.
I
did not notice what the heck that was.
Ow, why is there a headcrab here too?
Oh my gosh, there's so many guys here.
Go away.
Why aren't they infected?
Why are they infected with headcrab?
You bastard, please let me shoot you.
That was not great.
Oh my god.
Still... Oh my god.
Wait.
Spoilers, is it because they're with the Mr. G-Man?
Oh.
I hope they're doing that to themselves.
Nice health.
Did they blow themselves up or...
Oh.
That doesn't look good.
Okay.
Alright.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Ouch.
Wait.
That took so much of my health.
No.
That sucks.
Did so much damage.
I just wanted to break it.
Power generator down here.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's walk... Look around a little bit first.
Because... This exists.
Ah.
Took like half my... It took... Half...
Of my life!
Nice.
Okay.
AI Marine is pretty advanced.
They actively flank you and try to draw you out of cover.
They... Yeah.
They seem pretty smart.
I don't think I like that.
Oh, there's another one.
Ugh.
Wait.
I've learned my lesson.
What is...
Wait!
What's going on in here?
Can I stop?
Wait.
Maybe if I jump over.
Yeah!
I'm gonna take his gun.
Oh!
Ouch!
Okay.
I can't take the gun.
I tried.
Where the hell are we?
Okay.
Oh!
Is this...
The other side?
Um...
Oh, I can't take that.
Okay.
Okie dokie!
Okie dokie.
I think we can go down now.
Ugh.
Hit it with the crowbar.
What?
Hit what?
The one that expl...
The one that says explosives?
The one that said explosives?
Guys, what is wrong with you?
Oh.
Oh!
I need you to come back, please.
I need to...
What?
Okay!
Peace and quiet.
Oh.
Oh...
I'm playing...
Mission Impossible right now.
Wait, can I...
Blow this up myself?
Oh.
Yes.
Anyway, um...
Ah!
Third time's the charm, I suppose.
Oh no.
No, god.
Whyt?
I know...
Little dogs!
Please!
Little dogs, NO!
Okay, little dog.
Little dog, don't do it.
Don't do it.
I lived.
Wait.
What?
I mean, we're gonna have to come back up.
Anything over there?
Not anymore.
You, in my existence.
I know there's more.
I saw him.
Any more?
Yes.
At first, if you don't succeed, try and try and try and try again.
He gave his honor... Wait.
His life, not for honor.
He didn't even... He didn't even give it for me, either.
I think I heard another pup.
100% heard another pup.
I don't know where he is.
Look at him just coming on.
He's just coming his way.
He's just...
Taking his time.
Oh, he's so cute.
Just waddling along.
Maintenance area.
Okay.
I have to be wary, I believe.
Nice.
Is there someone else in here?
Okay.
There's a lot to explore around this area.
Let's go down some more.
See where this leads to.
Oh.
What is that?
It was a... It was a... Oh gosh, they're like leeches.
There's leeches in the water!
Wait, are they actually leeches?
Free tapeworm?
Nasty.
I think they are fish.
What?
What's happening?
Hold on.
Save.
New save.
Nice.
Okay.
Maybe we'll see if they start hurting us.
I'm at 60...
Where is he?
He's like, I don't want to get out of my bath!
Oh my god.
You're powerful.
Ugh!
So far...
They're not hurt...
Whoa, this guy is like, actually flying.
Can I kill him?
Wait, let me try with my crowbar.
Oh!
What?
How did that kill me?
How did that hurt me?
Oh!
Okay.
Maybe they are bad.
They...
They take...
They are hardy though.
These guys take a hit.
Do you hear this?
Whack, whack, whack, whack.
Whack, whack, whack.
These guys are so thick!
Whack.
Oh!
More!
You!
Ah!
Oh, it drained the s...
It drained the room!
It drained all the...
Stupid leeches!
What do you mean I have no helmet?
Am I supposed to?
Can I go through here now?
Oh, it got on my face when you crouched.
Ah!
I see, I see.
And run!
No, no, no, no.
Green.
Run!
Okay.
Very nice.
So...
I turned on the power.
So now we can get the guy going.
The little...
Our little...
Car.
I suppose.
The fan.
Oh my god.
No.
The guys are back.
No, I hear them.
I did save, I just saved.
Over.
I'm saving again.
Because I'm scared.
Wait, they're coming from the other side.
Yeah!
I wasn't moving!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Stupid.
They're strong.
Oh no, I'm reloading.
Wait.
Wait, I also have grenade.
Oh wait.
This thing.
But this would be the perfect time to use you.
Okay.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put it down.
Um...
Put it on the wall?
Oh.
They'll blow up.
Probably.
I panicked, guys!
I put it on the floor!
I panicked!
Mister?
Hey mister?
I think I messed up.
Shoot?
Oh, they'll hear it?
They did not hear it.
Wait.
There we go.
Just walk past it.
I'm dancing.
Where are they?
Wait.
Oh, I think they haven't come down yet.
Hello?
Wait.
Why haven't...
Oh, I think they have to finish their little dialogue first, no?
They went back out?!
They only come down once.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna restart.
Okay.
Alright, let's...
Let's try this again.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Oh, be careful.
My turn!
Greetings, free...
Free Mint.
It is my birthday!
Shows!
Hold on.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Shows!
Okay.
Six shots.
What?
I've got six shots.
And no armor.
And no...
No.
Oh.
There he is.
Why did he explode?!
Um...
I have three health.
Three HP in a dream?
I just keep saving.
If I am an...
Oh god, I hear him.
What is...
What would be the best gun to use, you guys?
What do you think?
Maybe this one?
Cause it's like...
Pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew?
Sky.
Send your shotgun again.
Okay.
Well, we're done with the...
Men for now.
Maybe.
I don't know why...
Wait.
Oh yeah.
This is where they first came out.
Okay.
Alright.
What does this do?
Oh, this opens the door.
That's right.
Smush the bug.
And I'll do it again.
Alrighty.
Okay.
The SMG is the most hated weapon.
They only use it for the grenade launcher.
It has.
Oh, how do you...
How do you use that though?
Is that what the little six is down there?
Oh, if you right click, it will fire the grenade.
Oh, okay, okay.
Cool, cool.
Thank you.
I'm just gonna save again.
Sorry.
Okay.
So now...
Are you still alive?
Oh my God, he really is.
He's holding on.
I'm never gonna make it.
Oh.
Yes you are.
You better go on without me.
No!
Oh!
Okay.
You missed some revolver ammo down the ladder.
Which...
ladder?
Oh.
Well, I don't have to go down the ladder anymore.
This one?
Ah!
Thank you.
Okay.
So now...
Um, wait.
How...
Do I...
How do I do this?
Weakest knees ever.
I mean, my guy is at three HP.
I think...
I think he has an excuse.
It's gonna be very tough with three HP.
Yeah, probably.
How many times a year do you think I could claim it to be my birthday before mint notices?
Please don't do that.
I...
I go by otter system.
There's no way that I can remember everybody's birthday.
So please don't...
Even have that cross your mind.
Yeah, don't abuse it.
Please.
Because I will stop singing for people.
And I...
You know, I don't mind singing for people.
I like it.
I think it's a lot of fun.
But...
Yeah.
I feel like...
I feel...
I...
I don't even...
I don't even want to think of that thought.
How can we do this, guys?
How do I go back down?
Because the entrance was blocked.
Don't say that.
Ugh.
What is it?
Weak ass?
Is that what he's saying?
Jump across.
Wait, jump like here?
The bridge that collapsed just outside.
Wait, where?
Oh, here!
Oh, I see.
Thank you.
Ah, ah, ah.
Thank you, thank you.
I completely missed it.
Okay.
I was like, jump across!
Eek!
Ah!
Oopsie!
I panicked.
I might have panicked a little bit.
I might have panicked.
Just like a tad.
Good thing she didn't panic.
To be fair, you have like 3 HP.
Yeah.
I think I have a reason to panic.
He's not gonna notice me, is he?
Do I hear any more sounds?
Whoa!
Oh!
Okay.
That's where that is.
Alright.
Hmm.
Hey mister!
Oh, come on.
This sucks.
Cheese him.
Okay.
Guys.
3 HP!
Oh!
That's how that works.
It like, does not shoot very far at all.
Got it.
Cool.
Do these even do damage to him?
Or...
3 HP.
Half-Life 3 confirmed.
Okay.
I'm not gonna be your savior, buddy.
Don't put all that pressure on me.
Wait, I think he...
Has a moment after he does this where he like, kind of like...
Okay.
Do the stomp.
She stomp.
She do another stomp.
Then once this explodes...
Then he like, shakes his head.
Never mind.
Can I shoot him in like, the face?
He's like, shaking his head like, no, you cannot do that.
Go while the stomp is...
Charging.
Come on.
Go left.
Distract him from the other window?
Let's try.
Oh!
I'm dead.
I forgot to pick up this ammo.
Oh, wait.
I don't think I can get down, you guys.
I'll die.
This is probably the worst situation ever.
Jump to the ladder.
Okay, okay.
This is the worst situation ever you could be in.
Oh!
I was so close.
I'm not soft-locked because I have saves.
So we'll be okay.
But, you know.
I'm never gonna make it.
You better go on without me.
Okay.
All right.
I am...
I'm gonna go on.
Sorry.
Okay.
Guys, I might have to just...
Hey!
Hey, big buddy!
Yeah, I'm going.
All right.
The bridge!
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Well, I was gonna get the ammo, but...
Yeah, I think it's just...
Because there's ammo down there.
But I think it's just better...
Safer to maybe go with the bridge.
Huh?
Yeah.
Ugh!
Wrong tunnel?
Wait, what do you mean wrong tunnel?
Don't I need to go to the thing?
To the cart?
I need to go to the left tunnel?
Oh!
Oops.
Wow.
Wow!
Okay, well that...
Works.
Nevermind.
This is so stupid.
Oh, you gotta keep running!
Oh!
I didn't know he would come after me.
Okay.
Sorry, guys.
I should've saved.
I'm so stupid.
It's fine though.
It's fine.
Come here!
We were gonna make it.
Yeah, we got the 2 HP back.
Such a...
Okay.
Oi!
Alright.
So I just gotta keep running?
I saved!
Run, run, run.
Run,
run, run, run.
Get in the door.
There's a health pack.
Yeah, I saw the switch.
But he's camping now.
This is the Minto content.
We're playing on actual hard mode.
I see the switch over there.
Shit, shit, shit.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, now that I know what it looks like in there, I'm gonna try and get the...
Try for the...
Oh sh...
I wasted too much time.
There we go.
Okay.
I'm gonna try for the switch first, maybe.
Beeline to the console, pretty much.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Switch first.
See him?
What's going on out there?
I got him?
Whoa!
And I didn't even...
I couldn't...
I didn't even know it.
I died to electricity.
I think...
Careful of the rail.
I think everything's a little charged right now.
Okay.
Go?
Oh, there we go.
Wait, I'm scared that the guys are gonna come back, though.
Oh, shoot.
No, no.
There's health in here?
There is?
I tried...
Trying to find it, but I couldn't see it.
Ooh, what was that?
The boxes.
These?
Can I...
Walk on this, or will I die?
That's why you're the best, boss.
Corner by the lever.
Thank you!
Oh, I see it!
Oh, my...
Oh!
Holy...
Let's go.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Thank you, guys.
I didn't even see that at all.
I thought...
I saw some people saying that there was health in there.
But I thought they were saying it was like one of the wall packs.
One of the wall thingies.
And so I, uh...
I was like, I don't...
I was like, I don't see it.
You still alive?
He's still kicking.
Alright!
I was like...
...
save.
And...
...
Top speed!
Oh, uh...
Wow.
Sturdy.
Oh...
Freeman, I've been waiting for you.
You have?
One of your scientist pals said to give you a message.
You're supposed to take this old rail system up to some kind of satellite delivery rocket.
I don't know where it is exactly, and the old guy was so worried about getting out of here alive, he didn't tell me.
Main thing is, the military aborted the launch, so when you do find the rocket, you'll have to get up to the control room and launch it yourself.
Oh!
He said something about a Lambda team needing the satellite in orbit if they were ever gonna clean up this mess.
I'm a rocket scientist now.
What?
Take a little damage, but I can make it.
Did you just...
But, I can't take much more of this.
Wait!
Get off, Bernie!
Get off the rail!
I mean, Barney.
Fucking... I can't remember your name.
Barney, no!
No!
He's li... No!
I can't move!
Get off!
Come here.
Okay, why not?
I don't wanna die...
No!
Oh!
Why didn't you do anything?
He was like, I took a little damage, but I'm okay.
And then...
He lasted for his cutscene, and then he died!
We'll go in slow motion.
We'll go in slow.
Where is it?
Wait, oh!
What just happened?
Wait, how did I die?
How did I die?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Okay.
Freeman, I've been waiting for you.
One of your scientist pals said to give you a message.
You're supposed to take this old rail system up to some kind of satellite delivery problem.
I don't know where it is exactly, and the old guy was so worried about getting out of here alive, he didn't tell me.
Don't worry about it!
What?
Okay, he'll live now.
He'll live.
He'll live now.
Okay.
Let's see.
I have to see this.
Okay.
Oh, why am I dying?
Why am I hurting?
Wait, why am I hurting?
Oh, I'm getting electrocuted!
Oh!
I didn't realize.
Freeman, I've been waiting for you.
One of your scientists pals said to give you a message.
You're supposed to take this old rail system up to some kind of satellite delivery rocket.
I don't know where it is.
Uh, okay.
Okay.
Does this just...
Does it go in the water?
Oh, yeah.
See, there we go.
See?
We're fine!
Everything's all fine.
I'm taking it easy.
Oh, never mind.
I'm still taking it easy.
What could be down here?
Oh!
Electricity.
Yeah, we know this is electric.
We know.
Do I crouch?
Oh!
Okay.
Uh, how am I supposed to know?
Okay!
Save?
What's that sound?
That doesn't sound very good.
That sounds quite spooky.
What was that sound?
I hear head crabs, I believe?
This is so spooky!
Those are ghosts?
No!
No way!
They're screaming.
Why is it so spooky?
Oh, uh...
That's a...
Wait.
Oh.
Is that a dog?
Okay.
We're fine though.
Right?
Uh...
What?
What's happening?
What's going on?
Oh!
I missed my...
I was greedy!
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
I hear the screams of the damned.
Everything's fine?
You could stop the train at any time.
You know what?
You are so right!
Can I go backwards?
No.
I can only go forwards.
Worst Disneyland ride ever?
What are you talking about?
I'm really enjoying myself.
Wait.
You can.
So if I go...
No, no, no!
Wait.
I don't...
I think I can.
But I would still...
I tried reversing, but it just stopped.
Unless...
Hold on.
I'm gonna attempt...
I'm going to attempt this.
Ah!
Okay, hold on.
I don't want this guy bothering me any...
Any time in the future!
Why?
There we go.
Gotta switch the track somewhere else.
Oh?
Okay.
We'll get these guys preemptively.
I only have so much...
So much ammo with the revolver left.
So I don't wanna...
Is he gonna come out?
You know what?
Nevermind.
Okay.
Okie dokie!
And...
Stop!
15% Nice.
Okay.
Continue onwards.
Oh.
Six shots is all you need.
Yeah, but I need the ammo for the six shots.
I think.
I think that's how that works.
I think you like, get the ammo...
And then you say, six shots.
Which way are we going?
Straight.
Okay.
What if...
What if I go here?
Oh.
And I destroy these.
Yippee!
Okay.
That was worth it.
That was worth?
More revolver ammo?
I have 15.
There's your six shots.
Oh.
That doesn't seem good.
Wait.
Can I crouch this?
Or...
You could go faster.
I know, but I'm scared.
Can I crouch this and then let it go?
Or...
Just crouch?
Okay.
I didn't know if it was going to be so peculiar...
Or so particular.
You know what I mean?
Did we go in a circle?
I love revolver.
What's that?
Book it, book it, book it, book it, book it, book it, book it, book it.
OOOOOO!
Um...
Ha ha ha!
Uh...
Oh, it was a turret!
Ah!
We're here!
Okay, I believe this is our stop for now.
Shoot the sign this way...
Is that how it works?
Oh...
Sounds so bad.
Boy, I'm so scared.
He he he.
WAAAH!
Oh my god, you too?
No!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Reload!
The thrill!
Gosh.
Okay, I don't want to waste all my bullets though.
I don't want to waste all my bullets though.
Ouch!
Stinky...
I
don't have to worry about those.
All right.
What?
Stop hitting me.
Oh gosh, wait.
Okay, there we go.
At least these guys left a lot of their supplies.
At...
What the?
What was that?
Wait, what did it...
What?
What is this?
How...
When did I...
How did I get this?
Don't click again.
Oh!
I acc...
What do you mean I accidentally placed C4?
Wait, really?
Um...
Can she grab it with E?
Let me just see it.
I was just gonna try...
What was that?
Um...
Let me...
How many of that do I...
Oh!
Oh, I lost it!
Oh, well I guess there was no point in having it, huh?
Cause I placed it in like such a terrible location.
I didn't even know that I grabbed it.
What does it look like?
You'll get more later?
Okay.
I didn't even know I had it.
Well, let's see.
Anyway...
It's like...
Looks like a bag.
Okay.
I'll try and be on the lookout for it.
Well, there really wasn't anything in this area...
Well, I guess we didn't go in here.
Oh my
God.
Oh, I did get him.
Okay, good.
Take all your stuff...
Last danger.
The rocket!
Wah!
Oh my God.
Ow!
Even he died!
Wait, there's so many head crabs.
What?
That guy lit you up.
Oh my God.
Damn.
Look at there's...
There's so many of them.
Um...
I hear them.
I hear them creepy crawling now.
Grenade ready?
Maybe so.
Oh.
That did nothing.
Wait, they're like following him.
Let's...
Let's have him destroy them.
Oh.
Oh, he...
Yeah, see?
He killed all of them.
Easy.
I guess.
Okay, so here's a rocket.
Um...
Cool.
I love friendly fire.
Ah!
Oh my God.
It's a never...
Ending supply...
Of head crab.
Okay.
Can we shut the door, please?
Please?
Hello?
Ugh!
Okay.
Let's just leave.
That kinda...
That kinda suck.
The door is bugging out.
A little bit.
Yeah, it is.
Clear!
Okay, so...
To...
Switch to...
Another thing, we...
Press...
Or we shoot it?
Alright, yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
I guess I was going so slow before that I didn't destroy those.
Okay.
I wanna be able to make sure I get that one.
Hey!
Bing bing!
Wait, isn't there a turret here?
Haha, wait.
Save?
Okay.
Wait.
Is that it?
Oh,
I see it.
Hahaha!
Yeah, we need to raise the hook first.
Yeah, I know.
Dang, I don't think that got it.
Grenade it?
So true.
I have to have...
Perfect aim.
Which I have!
Perfect...
Aim!
Aw.
Sometimes panicking is the solution.
Hahaha.
Oh wait.
Um, so we have to somehow...
Get this little claw doodad up.
Um...
Hmm...
If I like really...
Uh...
Another switch up further ahead?
Like this way?
Or...
Oh, this...
Oh, this way.
Okay.
Oh!
Ouch!
I'm gonna redo this part.
Hahaha.
I'm just gonna redo it.
Since I know where the thing is now.
Okay.
Alright.
Redo!
Perfect!
I think I got it.
Remember you have to panic.
Ah!
You're right!
You're right.
Oh, uh...
It'll create a time paradox.
Ah, I forgot to panic.
That's the secret ingredient, baby!
Oh, wait.
You said there was another one.
Let's do it.
Okay.
I see it.
Where were we going before?
Now that I think about it.
Wait!
What's over there?
Now we're going straight.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
That's where it looped.
Got it, got it, got it, got it.
Okay.
Oh, spitty dog.
Am I even hitting him?
There we go.
I guess I could have gotten him from...
Here, but whatever.
Whatever.
Okay, interesting.
There is a ladder there.
We'll keep that in mind.
Sweet health.
Worth it, baby.
I see it.
I see some ropes!
Um...
Does that go all the way down?
Like if he was trying to...
We're going to get to about here, and then I'm going to blast him.
What?
I don't get the super jet.
Um...
I don't get it.
I don't like it.
Let's not...
I don't get it.
Um...
Let's get these boxes though.
I can get that.
Oh!
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh!
And...
What else?
What other goodies you got from me?
Grenade.
Actually, I did need that.
Oh wait.
Can I get back up here?
Um...
Did I mess up?
Wait.
It's kind of like at an angle.
We're fine.
Yeah, I got this.
Okay.
Crouch jump.
Who needs it?
All you have to do is be good at the game.
Crouch jump.
Who needs it?
We're going into unknown territory.
So I'm a little nervous.
Eh.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, he sounds so nasty.
Okay.
And there's a health.
I thought I killed him.
There's some more stuff under there though.
Oh.
I'm full on grenades.
But I wasted so many.
Okay.
Ah.
What's going on up here?
Oh.
What is going on up here?
Ooh.
Ah.
I did not recognize this area at all.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go.
I'm just like, I don't know what's happening.
I'm just here for the ride.
Oh.
There we go.
Literally here for the ride.
And that's it.
Shoot.
I think I missed again.
I missed, but so did he.
And you know what?
That's more embarrassing than me missing.
I think.
He's supposed to be good at this.
Me, you should have no expectations.
AI is supposed to be the smart one.
It's taking our jobs.
Woohoo.
Oh.
This is the ambush.
Ah.
Little warning, guys.
Would've been so nice.
Little warning would've been so nice.
Ah.
Oh.
I'm dead.
I think I...
I think...
Yeah.
I died.
Ah.
Oh, someone's there.
Can I jump here?
I'm going up.
You can't stop me?
Okay.
Where'd they go, though?
Ah.
What is...
Yeah, a ladder.
I know.
I'm just...
Preparing.
Okay.
Maybe this is fine.
Oh.
I'm moving this.
I was like, what's...
Holy.
I took so much damage there.
I took so much damage.
What an ass.
Good thing.
I got the HP, I guess.
Is there anybody else?
Yes.
Yes, there are.
Oh, wait.
Downstairs?
No.
Wrong way.
Uh.
Aw, man.
Shut up.
It's so loud.
Ugh.
I don't think they can hit me.
So I'm just going to leave them.
I think I'm just going to let them do their thing up there.
Okay.
All right.
Medical.
This guy sucks.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah, that's right.
Ugh.
Come on, revolver.
Don't let me down.
Come
on, I'll kill you.
Ugh.
Thank you.
I was shooting his feet.
Oh.
I was just trying to shoot anywhere that I could.
Bye-bye.
Okay, things are getting shot at.
What?
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god.
I didn't notice that I needed to overload.
Where are you?
There we go.
Okay.
Whew.
Grenade time.
It's...
Hit or miss for me.
Literally.
Quite literally.
Like, quite literally.
There goes my...
There goes my cart.
Okay, that's where...
See, I was looking to the...
To the right...
Okay.
All right.
I'm not gonna shoot this guy's feet this time.
You guys see that?
That was pretty good, huh?
Yeah!
Yeah, baby!
Good thing I saved!
Oh!
No, please, guys!
Please!
Do that again!
Ooh, his body.
Maybe I could get them first.
You know?
I think I might have gotten someone.
I think, actually, that worked.
I think I got someone.
For real.
I know there's a guy over here, though.
Wait, hold on.
Save, save.
There we go.
Uh...
Mister?
What if I...
Okay, hold on.
Just one more to be safe?
Yeah.
And I'm gonna throw off this wall?
Oh.
That didn't quite work as intended.
That's okay.
Oh, she...
Okay, cool.
Um, what about that gun?
Can I use that?
Or...
I hear another guy.
So, we're gonna...
No, I don't think...
I don't think so.
Alright, this is fine.
This is fine.
Um...
Nice.
Okay, cool.
Oh.
I need...
Don't worry.
Oh.
It's so dramatic.
You're doing great, Vito.
This game is tough.
Thank you!
I'm playing...
Something.
I'm somehow playing the game.
Oof, we had this.
I know.
This guy is so dramatic.
Uh...
I'm gonna actually switch over.
I'm gonna...
Save.
And we're gonna leave that health there.
Since I'm at 99.
There's no point in me taking it.
Out him!
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Ugh!
Okay, well, good thing I left that health pack.
And then good thing there's one here.
And then we're gonna destroy that!
What?
Oh.
Is there some gun?
Is there ammo?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
What was that?
Blylylyly, bleylyly.
Blylylyly.
Whh!
Uh...
Oh, my God.
I just eat bullets with the...
With the shotgun!
Oh!
I just eat bullets!
So bad!
Oh!
Oh...
It's so tanky!
Right click on it, but then I'll take damage too!
Hold on, I'm gonna retry.
Here, let's retry.
Wait.
This one.
Grenade them.
Ouch!
I got stuck on the wall.
Come here, come here, come here.
Come here.
What does right click with the shotgun do?
Oh, it uses both!
I see, I see.
Okay, good to know.
I learned.
I learned and I put what I learned to use.
Wow!
Sandwich!
Let's go!
What's wrong!
Um, is there anything else?
Other health?
And...
You know what?
I will save.
I think we're good.
Oh!
Just a box.
Is there anything in here?
Oh!
Yes, there is.
Sometimes.
Sometimes, there's things.
Just jump.
These are mostly all just boxes, actually.
Oh, dead man.
I love when they fight each other.
I don't have to do anything.
Thank you!
Okay.
Yeah, let them fight.
Yeah.
They have their little brawls.
No.
Oops...
Wait, hold on!
I'm gonna retry that?
And not stand so close.
Okay, too close.
There we go.
Okay.
It's like when you make the monsters in Doom accidentally hit each other and then they start infighting there.
So perfect.
Yes.
Wait, did I get it?
You had martyrdom as a perk.
Oh, there he goes.
I took still so much... I still took so much health.
Half-life!
The Grunts are more of a menace than the aliens in this game.
Actually, though.
I'm really... I'm really feeling that right now.
Oh, there's some boxes here.
What's this?
Sacred.
They're infighting.
Um,
I messed up.
I didn't realize I picked it up.
I think that's it.
No?
Press E.
It doesn't... It didn't work before.
Aw, what?
Scones!
Let's go!
Only in multiplayer.
Scones!
Oh, there's another health.
Yippee me!
Lucky, lucky.
Let's go!
We got it!
Oh my god!
Shut up!
Scones!
Let's go!
I don't know if that was...
Um, a...
really good amount of health, but...
you know what?
If it works, it works.
Okay.
All right.
Ah.
I don't remember what I had before, but...
Shut up, please.
Annoying creatures.
Everybody, all of you.
This is not us versus aliens or anything.
This is me against the world.
Love the hermit.
Thank you.
Put him out of his misery.
The guy was bugging out.
He didn't, he didn't, he didn't, you know.
He was, I put it, yeah, I really did just put him out of his misery.
What was that?
Oh, that's me.
I was like, what's that sound?
I don't know where I'm at, where I'm going.
Oh.
Um.
I was here before.
Yeah, yeah, wait.
Oh, this is a big old circle.
Because this is where that one health pack is.
Oh, and my... Oh.
Yes.
Oh, and my boat.
Hey.
Yeah.
Reload.
Thank you.
I will.
Yeah.
Does this work?
Okay, I'm not very good at using it.
Get me off of this.
Get me off of this ride.
All right.
Let's keep going.
Let's scones.
World of the story.
Minto hates scones and everyone that likes them.
What?
No, I...
Oh, no.
I did like a...
What's that sound?
We're fine.
I did a, um...
Uh, like a high tea...
Thing.
Not too long ago with some friends.
Oh.
Wait.
Please.
Rivers.
And they had scones.
And I actually quite like them.
Those scones.
Oh.
Wait.
I think I was pretty close to a hundred already.
High tea.
Yeah.
You know, like when you go and get the fancy tea and they give you macarons and tiny sandwiches.
That's what I did.
A fancy tea party.
Okay.
Pinkies up?
Absolutely.
And I got a scone.
And we were actually like kind of...
Will we see a rerun of the minto plushies?
Maybe in the future.
Can I throw so far?
I messed up.
Mister, you are going down.
That's not my last name.
That's my maiden name.
Okay.
Scones!
Oh my gosh, the fact that it has to keep reloading every time is so annoying.
I can take these guys out nice and easy.
Ah, so peaceful.
Scones!
I lost a little bit of health.
Oh my god, the loading is kind of giving me a headache though.
So let's move forward.
Wait, oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, please.
Okay, all right.
Save.
All right.
I have him flow.
Ouch.
Oh no!
I accidentally touched it.
It's okay, if I restart, I restart.
Wait, who's fist fighting?
Who is fist fighting over here?
I think I'm in trouble again.
Oh man.
Wait!
I see him!
Don't touch my man.
He's mine.
I want him.
I will protect him.
I tried.
You know what?
This is fine because I'll get my health back.
This is fine.
I'll get my health back.
Oh shoot.
Yeah, I do want.
I do want to take this stuff.
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
Oh!
I didn't...
I didn't get...
I did...
Oh!
Nice.
Okay.
Headcrab needs a promotion.
Let's let them do their thingies.
Yeah, give them a little...
Give them their moment.
Give them their space.
You guys, we're respectable, you know?
Oh, the yellow part is safe.
Excuse you.
Well, I didn't lose all my health this time, so...
We're already...
We're already doing way better than before.
Wait, where is he?
Funny.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, we're gonna get Barney out.
Barney!
Barney.
Don't die on me, Barney!
He held his own!
Oh, Barney!
You saved me!
Look at him pulling up his pants.
Get a belt, Barney!
God.
Oh.
Wait, did I grab those?
Yes?
You...
Something died down here.
You stay in here, okay, buddy?
You stay in here.
All right, before we do that...
Hold on, I'm gonna get my pistol out.
Oh my god.
I think head crabs may be the worst.
I think they might be.
My least favorite thing ever.
Wait, can I climb up here?
Can I climb up here?
Wait, uh...
Wait.
Am I dying?
Stupid.
Come here.
It actually did its job!
Aw, you made me break it!
What are we getting?
Oh, it's empty.
Purple drink.
Empty.
There was a battery up there.
No!
Should I just reload?
I at least have health here.
Ooh!
It gets you plus one HP?
Wait.
What do you mean plus one HP?
Like 101?
Or like 15 to 16 armor.
One soda equals one HP.
Oh, really?
I've been breaking the machines every time.
Oh, if purchased.
I'm hearing something.
I don't quite know.
Yeah, me too.
I'm just gonna save.
Let's just go.
And we're fine.
Golly!
Mister!
Oh!
What the hell is that?
That's not a Mister!
What is...
Is that a turret?
It's a...
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Can I...
Can I grenade it?
I like how I still have the C4.
I can just explode it whenever I feel like.
It's a guy on a turret.
I don't think that works.
Surely there's some health in here.
Surrender?
Okay.
Whew.
I don't...
I...
I didn't know.
What actually does that say?
E-men.
Freeman?
Freeman?!
That's me!
Wait a second.
Um...
What do you mean, surrender Freeman?
Hmm?
Is that on the other side?
They know my name!
Nice.
Okay.
Free man.
Come with me if you...
Okay.
Never mind.
You okay?
We'll just leave him here.
He'll find his way out.
I'd like to get my hands on the guy responsible for this mess.
Yeah, me too.
I'm gonna manually save.
Because if I wanna maybe redo that part, I'd be good too.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Okay.
So now, um...
What?
Because our...
Our boat doesn't go any further.
Unless...
Oh!
No movement check.
Please.
Maybe I can bait him over to here?
And then explode him.
Maybe.
Spspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspspsps
Guys, I died... to the electricity.
I think I should redo this part.
I'm not gonna lie.
I feel like I should redo this part.
What do you guys think?
I'm gonna try it.
Hold on.
It was the autosave, right?
This one?
Or...
Quick?
Yeah, the quicksave.
There's this one.
Um, we did all this.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then...
I just gotta get this guy first try.
I'll be happy to survive this with all my parts.
Okay.
Oh, now I hear him.
Now I hear him.
Okay.
I'm gonna save.
Alright, we're saving.
Okay, and then we're gonna...
Boom, baby!
Wee!
I took 20 damage, but that's better than the...
Than what we have before!
Woo-hoo!
Okay.
Surrender, E-Man!
And, uh...
I think it was just three, but that's fine too.
Okay.
And we'll go to the other side.
And we'll shoot...
These.
Very good.
For the future.
And,
uh...
Okay, so they're below me.
So maybe I can run into the other area.
Let's see.
Okay.
There is no other area.
Oh!
Ow!
No!
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
There is no other area.
I have...
I've since learned.
I've...
I've done a...
A scientific study.
It's just murder floor.
How do I do this?
Um...
Where is he?
Hey, mister!
Throw a grenade.
I can try and throw a grenade.
Check in.
Where?
Who is shooting at me?
Oh, there...
Oh my god!
The eyes of a hawk!
Ugh!
Okay.
We got him.
Nice.
That doesn't sound good.
Don't know how to feel about that.
Oh!
Where did this one come from?
Wait, what's over here?
Math...
And...
Bullets...
And health...
Wait, really?
I don't need any more bullets?
It's crazy.
Unboxing time.
Merry Christmas!
You guys got coal.
Sad, sad, sad.
Should've been...
Better good...
Better boys and girls.
Oh my god.
Spitty...
Spitter.
Let's go.
Let's go!
I think I can just...
I guess I can just duck with these.
Looks like I got it.
Let's go!
I'm scared.
I'm gonna get ambushed though.
Hahaha!
I think I am about to get ambushed.
It's a turret.
Nimmie nightmare!
Thank you for the ring!
Oh!
I'm activating these.
I'm so silly.
Come back!
I hope you had fun with...
Elden Ring.
I'm playing...
Old, old boomer shooter.
Um...
What you hear?
Is a turret.
That I will destroy.
Thank you for the gift of you guys!
Thanks, dog strings!
Wait, who was the other one?
Sorry, I missed it.
Oh, ducky!
Thank you!
Okay.
I'm gonna do my best.
Uh...
Oh, there's two of them.
There's two of them.
Wow, it took like...
Wow, they missed like almost every shot!
Yeah!
Okay, sir.
Thank you, Nano.
Thank you!
That was...
That was kinda funny.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm playing Half-Life for the first time ever.
Wait.
Was that another one?
I heard a beep.
Look, we got goop on the...
front of our...
ship.
Oh!
There is another one.
All the way down there.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
DC, thank you!
Um...
I'm gonna just blow this up.
Okay.
Guys, I set out to do something.
And I...
I...
I completed it.
I did it.
I said I'm gonna blow this up.
And I...
You know what?
That's exactly what I did.
Sorry.
I just recently...
Caught the C4.
I'm sniping with my shotgun.
Gotta make the game challenging.
Absolutely.
This game is way too easy.
Otherwise, this game is just way too easy.
Why did I do that?
When did I last save?
I've got a...
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
I have to redo this.
Alright, it's fine.
We got this.
We're gamers.
I got electrocuted a little bit.
That didn't go as well.
But...
We still have more health...
Than before.
We still have...
More health...
Than we did...
Last time.
Go in the fridge?
Fridge?
One full burst should take them out?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm trying... I'm like...
I'm like...
What's the point of using bullets sparingly?
If I have to do it...
Multiple times, you know?
Is this Half-Life 1 or 2?
It's Half-Life...
One.
You...
You're...
You're dead, Freeman.
You're dead.
Oh!
I didn't see the rope.
I fell...
I fell straight into his little trap.
His little...
His little tentacle trap.
You're dead, Minto.
I am!
I'm reloading.
I'm so sorry, guys.
I'll save after.
I promise.
You know what?
I'm...
I am gonna throw a grenade.
Uh...
I don't...
How can I make it bounce, though?
Maybe...
Off this wall.
Nope.
Okay.
Very cool.
Here's the other bomb.
Oh!
This one?
Actually, I feel like if I use the double barrel...
I can probably take it out.
I got a little electrocuted, but we're okay.
Nice!
Hey!
That one went pretty smoothly.
Okay.
F6.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Yeah, right click with the shoddy is really good.
It's pretty dang good, yeah.
Okay.
Now once we get over there, I will save.
So we don't have to deal with these stupid...
Turrets again.
I hate.
Worth the two ammo.
So true.
Is there even anything in here, though?
He was waiting for...
Ah!
Oh, he even left the spray paint.
Wait, um...
Tea.
You're dead, Minky.
You're dead.
Oh my god.
I wasted it on a stupid headcram.
All right.
I guess there's really nothing in here.
And we save.
Ah!
Headcrabs are the most dangerous in the game.
They are such little sneakies.
They're so annoying.
Sneaky little suckers.
Okay.
Oh.
Taking it easy.
What is that?
Reverse!
It's Goku.
Who is that?
Okay.
Oh, I think the door was closing.
Hmm.
Maybe I've taken it too easy.
Okay.
Full speed ahead now.
Full speed ahead.
Ducking cover.
Is that actually what you're supposed to do?
Okay, here we go.
He doesn't notice me.
Oh!
That was so close.
Oh my god!
Wait, I almost died for real.
Oh!
Holy cow!
I almost died for real!
I almost...
How did he die?
I don't under...
I don't understand what happened.
But, um...
If it works...
He died because he was so intimidated.
By my...
You know...
Gaming prowess.
He said...
Whoa!
I thought you shot him.
Yeah!
Die, Freeman!
That's Phantom to you!
Okay.
Oh!
This is...
I think we're our...
No?
Actually, I'm not sure.
Grenades in the ready.
Die, Phantom.
You don't belong in this world.
Oh!
Uh...
We're fine.
Nope.
We're not fine.
We're...
No, please!
Does not buy Minky's hand.
She was once again given flesh.
I was called here by...
Humans!
Who wished to...
It's stinking.
This guy's ruined my mood.
No prizes?
No...
No Christmas presents?
No Christmas presents at all.
So sad.
Look at the handprint there.
It's pretty epic.
Oh!
I blew somebody up.
Somebody is dead.
Wait, what's...
Which cart is that?
Whose is that?
Your autograph from Toho lost for giveaway right today!
It's slightly banged up.
Thanks for being a swell gal.
Sorry.
It's a little banged up.
Might be tough for...
Shikishi to go in the mail.
Who's chirping?
Roger.
Good thing I...
Scones!
Hey!
How'd you know I was here?
Oh shit.
We're fine.
Okay.
And I reload.
Wall hacks.
Okay.
All right.
Save.
Let's go.
You'd think they'd learn.
I know.
They don't know who they're messing with.
Or rather, I think they do, but...
They're silly guys.
There's...
This is fine.
Oh.
There's no more?
Okay.
Who am I hearing?
Oh!
That's...
That is a C4, right?
That's a C4?
That...
That is it?
Yes.
Explosives, baby!
We...
We love to see it.
I keep hearing a little creature, but...
Around this area, but...
Peculiar.
Okay.
Is that...
My...
No, that's not mine.
Where do I...
How do I get to there?
It's just us, don't worry.
You sound so cute though.
He he.
Nevermind.
You don't need to growl at me.
I complimented you.
Oh, they're like in the air duct.
Oh, thanks.
She took it back.
Yeah, because did you hear it?
They're in the wall...
How do I...
How do I blow them?
Oh!
Aw, man.
I...
Uh...
Fire in the hole!
Oh, God.
Oh, I actually lived.
Fire in the hole!
The SMG?
Let's try it.
Peace and quiet, finally.
All right.
So maybe I just jump on over.
Okay.
I made it...
I made it sound so difficult.
Peak Looney Tunes comedy.
Wait!
So quiet.
Quiet.
Okie dokie.
Artichokey.
Would you still love hate us if we were a headcrab?
I actually think the headcrabs are very cute.
They look like horseshoe crabs.
So they're actually quite charming.
They're just annoying little...
bugs.
Okie dokie, chicken jockey!
That's not what I said!
Chicken jockey!
Flint and steel!
I am Steve!
I'm still not over it.
Readying my grenades!
Oh, ouch.
Wait, hold on.
Reload.
I think there'd be a wall.
Oh, a little further.
Oh, no, no.
A little.
And stop.
No, no.
Wait, no.
Back, back, back, back, back.
And, and, and this.
Perfect.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't see anybody.
First try.
It's like it's... It's like parking a truck, you know?
Parking a car.
Hmm.
I want to use that thing.
The big boy right there.
Oh, this part.
Okay, we're going to save it here.
And... Trap grenades.
Ah!
Ow!
Yeah, that seems about right.
Seems about right.
You think you're supposed to ram it?
I don't think so.
Because they've been...
They've been pretty adamant about me lifting these up.
That's why I had to go through the other way.
Did you ever get your car fixed, Minto?
I got a new car!
Iguana.
Yeah, I had to get a whole new car.
You can crouch when using it?
Ah!
Ow!
Oh, god.
I'm taking so much damage.
You missed.
If I use a grenade, will I even be able to throw that far?
Let's see.
Okay, hide behind it.
Okay.
Oh.
It's pretty good at taking...
Okay.
Run, hop, and throw the grenade!
Eh!
Or...
Wait, is it fully covered?
Oh, the last one was, wasn't it?
Congrats on the new car!
I hope it lasts a long time for you.
Thank you!
I appreciate it.
Easier to rush close to it.
If I rush and, like, just...
Blast him!
There's
way more guys here than I thought!
Oh.
I think the guy actually came out from behind it.
No, he didn't.
I lied.
Okay.
Um.
Hmm.
Nice.
Okay.
Here we go.
Grenade.
I'm gonna run up and grenade him.
Wait.
Oops.
Is he dead?
I got him, and...
I got a little bit of me.
Because I'm feeling bad.
Makes me feel alive.
What's up with having all these crates if they don't even put anything in them?
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Why?
I don't know where to aim with this thing at all.
Moral support.
It's just like, it's nice decoration.
Really...
It makes the place feel less empty, that's for sure.
It's meant to give you cover, then you choose to rush into it.
Ah!
I see, I see, I see.
It's hard to aim.
It is.
I think...
I'm just gonna save anyway.
I think we'll save.
A new save.
Instead of like a quick save.
You know?
Because we could always go back and do it better if we need to.
Now that I know there's three extra men.
Alrighty.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Please.
What is here?
We have our own little elevator.
And some stuff.
Back it up.
Some C4.
Okay, never mind.
I changed my mind.
Okay, so how do I use this?
I press...
Left?
And then...
Then right?
Left to drop, right to detonate.
Okay.
Did that work?
Guess we'll see.
Now that's how you use it.
And...
Oh.
Um, I don't think it worked.
How did I miss?
Um...
Oh, it's right there!
Ah.
Okay.
You can't pick it up, you guys.
Apparently, you can only do that in multiplayer.
Oh, set the elevator up without me.
Oh, I guess that could have been an option, huh?
Maybe there was something down there.
I don't know how that worked.
Holy cow.
Okay.
That should be good.
There we go.
Oh, my ears!
Wow!
Okay.
And they gave us an extra.
I needed two, though.
What happened here?
Eww!
Nice.
Asshole.
Oh!
This is where we're riding the train to!
Wait, what?
What is it?
What's up?
Oh, oh, we can see more.
Okay, that doesn't look so good.
Not, not much, baby.
Who you calling baby?
Nothing much, just watching Minto.
It's safe, actually?
It is?
I don't know if I trust you guys.
Who you trying?
Who you calling baby?
There's something really unsettling about gore from old games like this.
This game and Soldier of Fortune...
S...s...squick?
What's that mean?
Make you feel gross?
Usps.
Us, the wisps.
It means gross.
Usps.
What's in there?
Mysterious.
Is that a secret?
Could I have jumped onto that?
Then how would I get back on here?
I'm getting dizzy.
Could you think of a different way to do it?
I think, actually.
Okay.
Full speed!
Ah!
Oh, it is fine.
Hold on.
One moment, please.
Oh.
Just a little tickle.
Actually, I think it got rid of the armor that I had.
I think it didn't actually.
I don't think...
There will be more head to refill.
So true.
Can they just kill me?
Wow!
Where'd you come from?
Why'd you blow up?
They're so grenade happy.
They grenaded themselves.
They're such sillies.
Now this part's gonna be a little tricky, maybe.
Oh wait, I'm gonna reload.
Haha.
He shot a grenade into the box.
Alright.
Woo!
Okay.
Full speed!
Nice.
That wasn't so bad.
Oh my gosh!
This is the best part of the ride!
And then...
Okay, this is...
Oh my gosh.
You guys know...
You guys know Splash Mountain?
That's what this is giving me vibes.
And then on the left side, you see the little rabbit.
And he's like, Please no!
Don't throw me into the...
Into the patch!
And the...
And the fox is like...
I'm gonna throw you into the patch.
That's some fine driving, Dr. Phantom.
Thank you!
Oh.
Okay, interesting.
What do we have here?
Oh!
That's what we have here!
Can I just...
Shoot it?
I messed up.
But the other ones aren't active, so...
Should've doubled.
I know...
I thought...
I was close enough to get a single.
And then this is...
No?
Full speed!
Oh my god.
Ah!
There we go.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
I'm full speed!
Oh, I can crouch!
Oh.
I think they wanted you to crouch the whole time.
They're like, Hey, bozo.
Why don't you just crouch through it?
Yeah.
Stupid.
Hey!
Oh, he actually tried this time.
That was a waste.
Wait, wait, wait.
Go back.
There's some green stuff.
Part of Splash Mountain.
With the laser beams!
Yeah.
He just ate them, yeah.
Oh, cool!
Sorry, I like...
I like little details like that.
Just lock him from here.
There we go.
Now he'll never be a bother to us again.
You're too bothersome for this world.
Oh.
Okay.
What did he do?
He shot like six rockets at us!
What do you mean?
What did he do?
My man's innocent!
Oh!
Ouch!
Save!
Oh, I...
Oh, wow!
Oh, they move!
Whoa!
Can I just crouch here?
Oh...
You can.
I'll have impeccable comedic timing.
I'm not even...
I'm not even trying...
Wait...
Oh, no!
Don't make me do this again!
Go back!
Sorry, I can't read your name.
I'm stupid.
Here's the drop!
Wait, here's the drop.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That doesn't seem good.
The elevator's down there.
And I'm up here!
Come on!
If I do this...
Friendly fire!
Oh, I'm so dead.
If there's not another one...
Just kidding.
Oh, there he is!
What's swirling over there?
Oh!
Oh, the turret.
That's what's swirling.
Oh,
no!
Wait!
Oh, thank goodness.
It stops by itself.
Can you imagine?
What if I did this?
Does that take care of...
Oh!
Takes care of me, I guess.
Okay, hold on.
Look out below!
All right.
These ladders are so tricky.
Okay, then it loads.
I wish I would blow these up, though.
No?
I feel like I should.
Hold on.
Maybe if I, like...
What if I do this?
Oh!
Wait, but then it doesn't activate...
And shoot those guys.
I kind of want them to murder the other guys.
I hope you had a nice fall.
I'm too good at my job.
I'm just too good at what I do.
Okay, I know there's two of them now, though, at least.
Look at...
Look at that.
He's so...
He's so sensually hugging the wall.
What are you...
What are you trying to do?
Seduce me or something?
You creepy!
You creep!
He's like, Come here, baby.
Come here, baby.
Oh, yeah.
Let's...
Let's light him up.
Wait.
I'm out of grenades!
Uh-oh.
I'm out of grenades.
I know there's some in there, no?
Use the grenade launcher.
So true.
Did I get both of them?
I guess we'll hear.
The beeping of the turrets is so...
Stinking annoying.
Ouch!
How
did my health get so low?
Wait, I think it was already pretty low.
Ah!
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Alright.
We're good.
We got this.
Yeah, I'll just do what I did before.
And I'll shoot you.
And then we'll blow up in here.
And then I'm...
Oh!
Oh, I...
I missed it.
Oh!
Wait, I'm too good.
I'm too good!
And...
Yes!
We're gaming, we're gaming.
Oh, wait.
There's one more.
I don't like how it's switched to the...
Oh!
Minto Gaming.
Minto Gaming!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How many grenades can I carry if I...
Already am maxed?
Ten?
What?
Okay.
Okay!
Save!
Oh, it's broken!
Oh, no!
Wait!
What do we do?
Um...
Uh...
What does that mean?
This is not...
It's still electric.
Hmm...
We need to find another choo-choo ride.
I saw him.
I don't know if he saw me.
Oh!
He's the most perfect aim in the world!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Holy cow!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's get his ass.
Oh, he still got me.
He's hacking.
Medic!
That was pretty bad.
Not gonna lie.
That was...
Oh!
I hate this thing!
Oh, my God!
Oh!
If they can't see me, I can't see them, dars!
Oh.
Where'd he go?
Oh!
Oh, I got him, though.
Okay.
Got him before he could throw it.
Yeah!
This is some fear levels of AI destroying the player.
Okay.
You should play fear.
I've actually played...
Oh!
I've played fear before.
God damn.
Um...
Ouch!
Wait!
Okay.
So close.
The knockback.
I know!
Alright.
Okay.
Oh,
I can...
Should I...
Maybe throw it, though?
Alright.
Oh, my God.
What?
Oh, I don't think that worked.
Sorry.
Okay, hold on.
It will only kill him if it gets in the hole.
Yeah.
I know.
Try the launcher instead.
Maybe.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
I got stuck on the thing!
I got stuck on the ledge!
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Actually, we took no damage there.
That was pretty good.
Okay.
I'm gonna save.
I'm, like, here.
Oh!
Okay, a little lower.
Wait.
Hold up.
I think he's down.
Salmi, thank you so much for the rain.
Wait.
Why did they build this whole thing and not put a roof on it?
Like what?
I think you're... you're... you're...
Oh, I think that's a radio.
They're like just doing themselves a dis... like...
Ventilation?
There's no ventil... There's no time for ventilation and water!
You sweat in there!
And you... you... enjoy it, mister!
Yeah!
I don't trust those anymore after the last one exploded on me.
Why is there blood coming out of that?
There we go.
Can I get in there?
Let's see.
Oh, that's maple syrup.
I don't think so!
Ugh!
The crouch jump makes me dizzy.
Dang.
It's orange juice.
I could go for some juice right now.
Actually, let's go with you instead.
It's called a tank top for a reason.
It's stinky in there.
Stop me!
I didn't do this sabotage!
Uh-oh!
Did you throw that?
No.
Stupid.
Yeah, I'm gonna kill you and your buddies.
Dummy.
You have killed, like, a lot of their buddies.
I've killed...
Name a buddy that I haven't killed.
What's that green thing up there?
Oh, we're, like, outside.
Whoa!
Wow!
It's so cute!
Everything's so green out here.
Even my...
Even my crowbar is green.
Why is everything so green?
They must know it's a great color.
Wait!
Oh!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Um, just kill me.
Sneaky.
So evil, right?
Maybe.
Oh, come on.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, there we go.
Freeman.
Wait.
Um, where are you going?
He was like, My buddy!
He scared me.
You know what?
This is...
This is the...
This works.
This works, I suppose.
Why didn't the sniper...
Why did the sniper only wait until I was on that side?
Kind of annoys me.
You think I can get him?
Hmm...
My gun is even green!
I mean...
Hiya!
That was so close!
That was basically a goal!
Just wanted to be with his buddy.
That was so close!
I don't think it got him though.
Oh!
I heard...
Death sound!
I heard death sound!
Yeah...
I heard a goal...
Nice!
Let me get my health and peace, please.
Okay!
Um...
Anyway...
Oh
no...
Scones!
Medical...
Attention...
Is that it?
I bet...
Mr. Skippity Toilet himself is gonna be up in there.
Probably...
Oh gosh...
This looks like a battle arena for sure.
Uh...
My health is not looking so great, so I'm gonna save the game in a new save instead of a quick save.
I don't wanna overwrite anything, you know?
I don't know.
Oh...
Wait, what if I use this and just blast everybody who comes through?
Oh, it doesn't go up any higher.
Um...
Who's coming through?
Anybody?
Anybody.
It's like, so quiet.
Hmm...
It's a really nice night though.
Heh heh.
Uh...
They're very patient.
So am I.
I could wait here forever.
I think we gotta go in.
Oh, I hate the sound.
Oh!
That's a lot of explosives.
I'm...
They get this...
That's my buddy's handprint.
Oh, buddy.
Oh, sorry.
That's my buddy's handprint right there.
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
Maybe if I...
Okay.
They don't explode.
Don't explode that.
Why not?
Oh...
Can I...
Wait...
Could I...
Maybe I can jump over them.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
No, I can't.
Oh.
No!
I can't.
I'm too thick.
I'm too thick to get...
Just Mission Impossible it.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do I can't... I can't... figure out... Oh wait,
I can grab them.
I'm so stupid.
I forgot that... that's a thing I can do.
Okay, if I like... Alright, let's see.
Um...
Don't touch it.
Don't move.
Nope.
Oh my god.
Please stop moving!
It's so frustrating.
Okay.
And I...
Actually, like, get up on here and then crouch and...
Walk.
Aw yeah, baby.
She's trying to sneak around, but she's...
Tommy taking the clap of her...
ATV keeps alerting the guards.
Yay!
Alright.
Save.
Knock knock!
Oh, there we go.
Grandpa!
We're fine.
My thing may be too slow.
You know what?
Okay, here, we'll do this.
Who ordered this operation anyway?
Yippoo!
I just saw him run!
Great throw, thank you!
Hello?
No!
Okay, nevermind.
Uh...
Trying to see if there's like a...
Avoid motion while retinal scan is in progress.
Beep beep beep beep beep...
Shooting at props?
No!
Sometimes their things are...
Radios, no?
No!
The launch!
What's this?
Oh!
Okay.
What's...
What's that mean?
Let's go...
Oh my gosh!
Santa!
We're gonna blow up Santa!
Beep beep beep beep beep beep boop!
You know what?
I am just gonna save.
Whatever.
Oh!
There's a health thing right here.
I think I missed.
Stay down.
Okay, that might be the guy that I missed.
Oh!
Come on, come on!
Norad tracks Santa!
Exactly!
Really?
Beep beep beep beep boop boop boop!
Beep beep beep boop boop!
Oh!
There's so much science happening in here.
Or there was!
Grandpa!
What's this do?
Oh!
I broke it, actually.
I think going in here is...
would make me go insane.
Whoa!
Cells!
Wikipedia!
Whoa!
I guess we're just gonna launch it then.
Hold on.
Just a...
See?
I'm blowing up their...
radio!
What about this?
Okay, I give up.
Alright.
Launch!
Can I see?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
There goes Katy Perry!
Hey!
You're open up!
But one different dimension!
I'm going blind!
She's being blasted into space!
Bye Katy Perry!
Yay!
This is sick music playing.
Who turned up the tunes?
What do I do?
One more time!
Just jump?
Jump where?
Go into the hole?
Okay.
I'm scared here.
I'm scared here!
Oh!
There we go.
Alright.
I'm a professional.
There we go.
Congrats on...
Launching a rocket...
For no reason!
Thanks!
Go back further.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Oh.
Thank you.
I might actually call it here.
Depending.
Oh!
I'm starting to get a little slippery.
Oh yeah!
They're giving us all the goods!
What's that?
What is...
Oh!
Those are more C4s, no?
Can't carry anymore.
Drive the train first.
This one's quick.
Lucky!
Let's go!
Oh.
Oh!
I forgot to press...
Wow!
We upgraded our ride!
Apprehension?
Wait, no it's not!
Floor it?
What?
What if I floor it even harder this time?
I don't think that works.
You may need to get off the ride!
That's not how it works at Disney World!
I would like to not be on a little thing though.
Um...
Wait.
Please.
Please!
Ah!
Reloading!
Maybe this is a good...
Spot.
I would like to get off Mr. Freepin's Wild Ride.
Ah!
Good place to end, maybe.
Good place to end here, maybe.
We...
We, uh...
We should save.
Let's see what's down here.
I am having...
Oh, there's like...
Oh.
Oh, damn.
No way.
Oh, please!
The one spot I could get stuck on, I did.
Wait, there was another...
Mati!
Thank you so much!
Oh my goodness, there's so much in here!
Thank you so much for the time you have to thank you!
Uh...
Oh, now we're down here.
Okay.
We've managed to avoid drowning.
Are there...
Oh, I'm taking the stairs.
Like, I'm...
Not...
Able to...
Swim.
Where...
And go wherever I please.
Ah!
Don't even know where I am!
I'm lost!
What the hell is that?
Ew.
Not the gurgle.
This is just a big ol' rock!
Um...
Yeah!
Yes!
Uh...
Yeah!
Oh!
Finally!
Thank you!
The game said...
Hey girl, you need some help?
We got you, girl.
We got you.
Oi!
I love watching the aliens just do their thing.
He's picking them like he's picking bugs from a monkey.
Hey!
Dang!
You'll take...
You'll really eat them bullets sometimes.
Ooh, the flashing lights.
Oh!
Yeah!
Keep taking those guys down!
Do my job for me!
He's doing a mukbang?
Wait.
I hope I didn't just...
Accidentally deplete that...
With no reason.
Uh...
Okay.
Alright.
I feel we're like...
Slightly in the middle of the...
Of the...
The level now.
Actually, I don't know what to do here.
Back in the water.
I have zero memories of this part.
You repressed it, probably.
Right side.
Oh!
I see!
We were on that side.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm going to...
I'm...
I'm stopping myself.
This was so much fun though!
Thank you guys for...
More...
For more...
Half-Life.
Um...
I'm making sure that I look at the right side.
So that when I start the...
Uh...
Start next time.
I can be like...
The right side.
Is where I need to go.
So...
Yeah!
Thank you guys!
Thank you for your help too.
Helping guide me.
And all that fun stuff.
Um...
This has been a lot of fun.
And...
Yeah!
Um...
They did great tonight.
I can assure you...
The Marines...
Give everybody a hard time...
On their first playthrough.
We're...
We're making it work.
Thanks for the super fun stream.
Thank you!
Yeah!
Have a good rest of your night.
You too!
Uh...
Otsumito!
Everybody!
And...
I will see you when I see you...
Next time!
Oh!
Tomorrow...
Pretty hot dog stream.
Thanks.
What was I gonna say?
I didn't kill any Barneys this time!
Woohoo!
That's one thing I was gonna say.
And...
Uh...
Well...
Hailey to Waspin got arrested!
Are you sure?
What do you mean am I sure?
Arigato!
Choo!
Uh...
I think I didn't kill him.
Yeah!
Uh...
But...
Um...
Tomorrow...
Is...
Is Thursday, right?
So I have two streams.
Um...
One will be a midday stream.
And then...
Um...
I will also be on Doki Bird's channel.
Uh...
That night...
I will just be hanging out while she plays Visage.
And I will be telling her...
To...
Do stuff!
Yeah!
You did kill one or two.
No!
Oh...
I did?
She didn't directly kill any Barneys.
I wouldn't directly kill Barney!
Electricity!
I took a hit.
But I could take more.
And then he took another step.
And he's like...
I don't know if I could take any more of this.
That did accidentally happen.
Tentacle Barney.
I don't remember that guy.
He must have not been very important.
You're the MVP of the Visage...
Visage...
Streams.
We'd be there forever otherwise.
But yeah!
Otsumito!
Everybody!
Thank you so much!
I will see you guys...
When I see you next...
Thank you!
We're sticking around till the very end.
And I will see you...
Next time!
Otsumito!
Itte rashai!
Bye-bye!